[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
eine leckere kartoffel beilage die es
fast jede woche bei mir gibt und zwar
machen wir leckere kartoffel matches aus
dem ofen und dazu reiche ich noch einen
leckeren selbstgemachten sour cream dip
für die kartoffel badges benötigen wir
kartoffeln die schale lasse ich immer
mit dran die schmeckt total lecker und
steckt voller vitamine wichtig ist nur
dass wir sie vorher gründlich waschen
außerdem etwas olivenöl currypulver edel
süßes paprikapulver etwas kurkuma und
salz und pfeffer
nachdem die kartoffeln unter fließendem
wasser gründlich abgespült wurden
schneiden wir sie uns in kleine spalten
[Musik]
wie dick oder wie dünn die matches
schneidet ist nun vollkommen euch
überlassen ich mach das mal ganz gerne
so dass sich die kartoffel erst halbiere
und mir dann die stücke von der
kartoffel abschneide
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann alle kartoffeln geschält
habt gebt ihr sie direkt auf ein
backblech das plötzlich habe ich vorher
noch mit einer dauer bach folie
ausgelegt ihr könnt selbstverständlich
auch ein backpapier nehmen
nun geben wir unsere gewürze direkt auf
die kartoffeln
geschmacklich passt jetzt auch noch
rosmarin oder muskatnuss sehr gut zu den
kartoffeln
allerdings zeige ich euch in diesem
video bewusst die variante mit gewürzen
die jeder zu hause hat nun kommt noch
dass olivenöl mit dazu und hier braucht
ihr wirklich nicht viel denn die
kartoffeln sollen nicht im schwimmen das
soll alles noch richtig schön knackig
und genießbar sein und deshalb reichen
meistens schon zwei bis drei esslöffel
nun vermengen wir alles mit den händen
und verteilen das gut auf dem backblech
so dass keine kartoffeln übereinander
legen während die kartoffeln im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 10 grad
für 25 minuten backen zeige ich euch
schon mal die zutaten für unsere
leckeres sauer green fee benötigen creme
fraiche saure sahne oder schmand gehen
aber auch außerdem etwas salz und
pfeffer ganz wichtig ist auch ein
spritzer essig desweiteren benötigen wir
oregano und etwas knoblauch
[Musik]
für die zubereitung werden jetzt ganz
einfach alle zutaten mit der creme
fraiche vermengt
[Musik]
anschließend ist dies sauer cream auch
schon fertig und kann zusammen mit den
kartoffeln serviert werden
[Musik]
am allerbesten schmecken die kartoffel
wedges übrigens ganz frisch aus dem ofen
[Musik]
wer also etwas leckeres für
zwischendurch zaubern möchte oder sogar
eine schnelle beilage die zu allem passt
der liegt mit den kartoffeln ist genau
richtig
[Musik]
falls ihr das ganze jetzt nach machen
möchte dann freue ich mich sehr über
eure fotos oft instagram mit dem hashtag
pittis kitchen
falls ihr kein rezept video mehr
verpassen möchte dann hinterlässt mir
gerne ein kostenloses abo und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal auf die skis
kitchen
[Musik]